sir
wonder what now the standard approach
here is to make a magic lasso joke you
see she she ties people up with her
magic lasso
it's like bondage get it well no it's
not like bondage it is bondage you see
Wonder Woman's Creator had this vision
of a utopian future where strong
powerful women with good typing skills
got tied up a lot the 40's were
confusing time at any rate what this
means is that finding the subtle bondage
imagery and early Wonder Woman is kind
of like finding the Christ imagery and
Passion of the Christ B - Black Canary
now originally Black Canary was just a
plain old regular crime-fighting blonde
in fishnet stockings I'm not sure why a
crime fighter would be wearing fishnet
stockings maybe she was from an
alternate universe where vigilantes work
for tips she didn't have any powers
originally aside from the usual
gravity-defying bosoms
but eventually she developed a power
known as the canary cry that's one of
those comic-book name coincidences like
you know that a university professor
named dr. klaus von der murderer is not
going to be getting tenure d+ she-hulk
now what are the hoaxes major flaws lack
of fashion sense flat lifeless hair and
most importantly the Hulk is not sassing
well the she-hulk corrects all of these
problems and more appealing both to the
youthful lover of adventure and the
older reader with a very specific set of
fetishes unlike her more emotionally
unstable cousin the Hulk the she-hulk is
hoped out whenever she wants to be which
is pretty much all the time now on one
hand you lose the cool you wouldn't like
me when I'm angry angle but now that I
think of it I only like the Hulk when he
was angry I mean there's a reason that
the comic book isn't called the largely
unflappable dr. banner be Batgirl Robin
got his own name Alfred got his own name
they're not called Bat lad and Bat
Butler respectively and yet somehow
Batgirl fell prey to the same
nomenclatures the bat
the batplane and the Batmobile implying
that she's nothing but a redheaded tool
of the Dark Knight to be used as
necessary and discarded is needed in his
endless war against the underworld I'd
started petitioned to correct this
injustice but you know Robin and Alfred
are really lame names c+ storm now storm
is great she has awesome powers she has
a great name she has an actual
personality even Halle Berry's acting
can't ruin her and with her weather
control powers she actually has a reason
she's not cold in that getup
now she was created in the 40s she'd be
called weather girl and she's been half
of each issue telling weather man how
big and strong and smart he was or tied
up or both before that darn comics code
Authority came into play